Right now.
90% of the population of California
under flood
watch and America's
second largest city
is slammed by a relentless storm
Flash flooding, mudslides,
wind damage all across central
and southern California.
This is video just in from Santa
Firefighters pulling a person
out of that car
as water rushes around them.
There are scenes like these
all over the Los Angeles area.
Roads now closed.
Firefighters rescuing people
caught in these flash floods.
Santa Barbara County alone
responding to some 200 calls lik
In some cases, it's
better to leave the car home.
All water
and no pavement in the worst hit
Mudslides also blocking roads.
Nearly 60,000 customers
are without power.
And right now, the entire
community of Montecito
is under evacuation.
TV host
Ellen DeGeneres shared this vide
of an overflowing creek
near her home there.
Because there are a bunch of ver
rain this
weekend to our house
right here.
Deadly weather in California
where many areas now
have seen more than a month's
worth of rain in just the last 2
14 people have died, at least.
We look at all this
and you can see the impact there
Perhaps not surprisingly, the he
and the flooding have forced eva
It's also making it tough for pe
who are actually trying
to get to safety, as you can see
And in some of this video here,
CNN's Kyung
Lah and Camilla, burnout
are covering for this for both o
So, Kyung, first to you.
In the southern part of the stat
you're there on the one on one f
Clearly no one
commuting there this morning.
What are those conditions like?
You know, it's
really our first good
look at what we are standing on
because the sun
is just starting
to peek out from behind the clou
And this is the one on one freew
You can see
it is completely caked over in m
There is water that is completel
washed over this freeway.
And the reason why
this is completely shut down
and why this standing
water is still there
is because below
the freeway
is the Ventura River
in just 12 hours yesterday.
That river rose 17 feet.
So that is just gives you a snap
of what we are seeing here
in Southern California, in Santa
The airport there reports one da
that is
higher than the average month of
So just an incredible amount of
and it's impacting
tens of millions of people.
I'm going to take a look behind,
make sure no one's coming.
There are seeing our emergency c
beginning to move up
and down the one on one,
but they haven't been able
to clear this yet
because there are still
so many emergencies happening th
Is rain.
Rain is expected
throughout the morning here
in Southern California.
So, Jim and Erica, it is not ove
The morning commute
is still going to be happening.
And there's a lot of concern abo
what's going to happen
as people start to head to work
Camille, tell us what you're see
where you are there
and are the waters
expected to rise again?
Hey, Jim.
A very similar situation.
A lot of standing water
and a lot of cleanup to do in th
If you just take a look here
at the street, same scenario as
The sun is starting to come out.
So you can see
just how much water is all over
this neighborhood house after ho
having to deal with all of this
And unfortunately,
there was nothing
they could do to stop that water
I talked to
some of the residents yesterday
who were telling me,
you know,
I wanted to put those sandbags o
and I did it.
But it made no difference
because the water
still got into the homes here
and in many other communities ac
Santa Cruz County.
There's 32,000 people in this co
that are under evacuation orders
The sheriff's deputies going doo
over the last couple of days
telling people
to evacuate their homes,
to leave immediately
because of the dangerous conditi
You don't want to be in your hom
when it is like this.
And, you know,
not just the water,
but you're also losing power
in many of the areas.
We've seen crews
over the last couple of days
working to try to restore that p
But it's everything
put together
that makes it really difficult
for these residents.
I talked to people yesterday
who told me,
look, I'm just so tired of clean
of going through the rain
because it is coming
closer together in terms of the
a storm after another storm.
And so people are frustrated,
people are tired,
and it is becoming very dangerou
just like
in many other parts of the state
They're telling people
if you do not have to travel,
do not get in your car,
because, again,
the streets look like this.
So it is much better to stay hom
to try to be as safe as possible
Because, yes,
more rain is coming
in the next couple of days.
And so
they're starting to do anything
they can to prepare for that
next storm already Jim.
Erica, kept getting deeper and d
There was so much water
it was gushing in.
It knocked me over.
California already pounded by a
Cyclone last week
that brought hurricane force win
torrential rain,
flooding and mountain snow
is now in the throes of yet
another atmospheric river storm.
A weather system transports
a high concentration of moisture
and dumping epic amounts of heav
We are into atmospheric river
number five.
But just last week,
several counties in the state
were experiencing
the exact opposite
exceptional drought
marked by the deep red.
On this map,
it's considered the most severe.
Although California's recent
parade of ultra wet storms
have not completely reversed
the decades
long dry spell, flood warnings
have now replaced
severe drought warnings in the
same areas.
This weather
whiplash is
forcing California
to face the dilemma of
how to manage flood waters
as the state experiences
dramatic shifts
from drought to downpours.
Experts tell CNN
part of the solution is drawing
levees back
to allow rivers
more room to safely flood.
We have to let
our rivers flow differently
and let the rivers flood a littl
and recharge our groundwater
in wet seasons.
Climate scientist
Peter Gleick says
levees have effectively protecte
communities in the past,
but they're not designed
for the climate challenges of to
He says containing flood waters
means less
water is available to seep into
underground aquifers.
A desperately needed water sourc
for farmers and communities
for drinking
water during extreme drought.
Instead of thinking
that we can control all floods.
We have to learn to live with th
Glick says that means communitie
will have to get out of the way.
Entire cities and towns
would need to relocate.
These changes are absolutely
easier said than done,
but they have to be done.
We have to redesign
flood insurance policy
so that we're not rebuilding hou
once they've been damaged
in the same places
where they're going to flood aga
We have to design flood
insurance policies to encourage
to move away from flood plains
so that we can open up the flood
And when we get those floods
there will be less damaging